That was bad. It shouldn't have skipped from here back up to the next letter.
The o in Hello is the beginning of a new vowel group, but the program didn't
count it that way. It looks like it didn't run these lines, because inside
vowel group is already true. But that's a mistake. Inside vowel groups should
be false, because the letter before o was l, which is a consonant. How would
you fix that? I'll make a few suggestions and you can pick the one you think
will work and implement it. Should we remove the condition, if not inside vowel
group, so that we always increment counts for vowels. We could change the
condition of the inner if block from not inside vowel group to count equals
equals 1. We could set inside vowel group to false right after count plus plus
or set inside vowel group to false when letter is not a vowel.